at least three Palestinians have been
killed and nearly 30 others have been
injured during an early morning Israeli
raid on Janine refugee camp in the
occupied West Bank four of the Wounded
are said to be in a critical condition
Israeli media are reporting that five
soldiers were also injured and had to be
flown out by helicopter an Israeli
helicopter has also bombed a Target in
the camp it's the first airstrike there
in nearly 20 years neither Abrahim has
more from occupied West Bank
we are now on our way to Janine in the
north of the occupied West Bank where
the Israeli raid is still ongoing and
we're seeing an escalation that we
haven't seen in years which is Israeli
Choppers bombing Palestinian targets
Israeli army they say that they use that
to be able to evacuate facilities who
have wounded after they were ambushed by
Palestinian fighters in the Janine
refugee camp we're hearing that six
soldiers were injured and as a result
we've seen an intensifying use of Fire
by Israeli forces and
Palestinians were killed and 26 were
injured now we know that some of those
cases are critical so we might be
expecting those numbers to escalate it's
a critical situation at the Janine
refugee camp and people are calling upon
the International Community to intervene
they say that Israel is using excessive
force against Palestinians
okay let's go to Imran Khan Who's Live
For Us in West Jerusalem Anita saying
that this is an escalating situation
what is Israel saying about this
well Israel has actually confirmed that
there was a massive exchange of gunfire
their words in Janine refugee camp they
say that one of their vehicles came
under an improvised explosive a device
attack uh damaging the vehicle they
haven't confirmed that Israeli soldiers
were injured but after that happened uh
helicopter gunships fired Rockets into
uh Janine refugee camp now that's a
major escalation we haven't seen
helicopter fire being used in that way
in the occupied West Bank since uh the
second interfada in the 2000s so it is a
very serious escalation the Israeli Army
like I say have confirmed that use of
helicopter gunships but there's also
been other reactions as well but fazel
smartridge who's the Finance Minister
but he's also a minister in the ministry
of Defense he has said that it's time
now for a major operation across the
West Bank and he wants to convene a
security cabinet meeting so lots of
fiery language coming out there from bet
for Del spotro it's something that we
might expect him to say whether he
actually gets his way and there is a
major escalation and a a major operation
remains to be seen it's unlikely that
some of the more senior members of the
Israeli government will want that and
want that kind of escalation but
certainly uh confirmation there that
helicopter gunships were used in the
face of what we've been seeing over the
last few hours Imran plus that reaction
from the Israelis as well that that
those strong words that you're talking
about how the Palestinians responding to
all of this
well speaking on Twitter uh the
Palestine Liberation Organization
Secretary General actually said there is
a Fierce and open War that's being waged
against the Palestinian people
politically security and economically by
the occupation forces we're in the midst
of a comprehensive battle on all fronts
that requires the units of your people
in the face of this aggression an
unprecedented decisions that must be
taken in the emergency leadership
meeting being chaired by the president's
other Palestinians are gathering
together to try and see what they can do
to see what response they can get now uh
what we're hearing is one of the people
that was a target of that Janine Refugee
count raid was actually the son of a
Hamas leader Hamas have reacted on
social media saying uh that the fighters
engineering are more than capable of
Defending themselves and taking the
fight to the Israelis so that may well
be the response coming from Hamas and
there might not be anything coming out
of Gaza other than that kind of rhetoric
hey man thank you very much indeed
that's him kind of talking to us from
West Jerusalem